c'est une véritable guerre qu'il faut
mener compte les problèmes de pollution
et tout ce qui va avec
cette archive date de 1973 et déjà paul
emile victor explorateurs scientifiques
alertent les français sur l'état de la
planète
après plus de quarante expédition
polaire après avoir vécu avec les inuits
ce visionnaire milite pour la défense de
l'environnement l'eau et son principal
combat il est évident que l'eau polluée
partout l'eau des rivières polluées
partout l'eau des nappes phréatiques qui
commence à être pollué l'eau les nappes
souterraines profondes danse dont
certaines sont également pollué ne
pourra jamais faire face aux différents
besoins si elles ne sont pas traitées
et derrière cette pollution un seul
responsable selon lui l'homme alors
qu'il était un prédateur comme les
autres prédateurs c'est à dire faisant
sa tâche dans l' équilibre de la nature
il est devenu destructeur mais malgré
tout paul emile victor se décrivait
comme un optimiste
selon lui il était encore temps d'agir à
la condition que toute la population
mondiale se réveille sans une opinion
publique convaincu de l'urgence de la
situation la planète allait à sa perte
cette opinion publique c'est vous chez
vous c'est moi donc là nous pouvons agir
chacun dans notre petit cercle
une fois que nous sommes convaincus
j'espère que la plupart des gens sur un
jour convaincu et se sentiront concernés
eh bien ils font parler pour que
d'autres soient convaincus a concerné
pour qu'il y ait une opinion publique et
sous l'effet d'une opinion publique ont
remué du montagne en 1974 il crée le
groupe paul emile victor pour la défense
de l'homme et de son environnement
dans cette association il fédère tous
les scientifiques inquiets du sort de la
planète comme haroun tazieff ou encore
alain bombard il se rend aussi dans les
écoles pour éveiller les consciences des
prochaines générations
mon nom est donc volé lille victor
le directeur des expéditions polaires
françaises mais ce soir je vous parlerai
pas des eskimos ni les pingouins
mais des problèmes de l'environnement
c'est-à-dire des problèmes qui sont
vraiment importants en 1979 il publier
le livre jusqu'au cou et comment s'en
sortir
où ils aborder ce que l'on appelle
aujourd'hui le développement durable
paul emile victor meurt en 1995
[Musique]